we're going to start this morning in the
west where raging wildfires in
california oregon and washington state
are burning out of control at this hour
at least 35 people have died
officials describe conditions as quote
apocalyptic
smoke is creating dangerously bad air
quality including the worst air quality
in the world in portland oregon that's
according to one major index
jonathan vigliotti is near the front
lines in berry creek california jonathan
good morning to you
and good morning to you there is an
eerie silence among
all of this wreckage but when the fire
ripped through
there was chaos and we're hearing from
one family that was separated in it all
a mother who made it off in her car her
young son
and his grandmother in another car they
didn't make it far though
before they were engulfed in flames
across the west
thousands of homes and families ripped
apart
as these wildfires continue to rage
as families assess the damage from
violent wildfires
flames continue to threaten more
communities
in southern california sunday officials
ordered additional evacuations due to
the bobcat fire northeast of los angeles
we're all living through very tough
times and then you superimpose upon it
a devastating fire like this and so it's
hard it's really challenging
flames have decimated entire
neighborhoods
and thick smoke is creating some of the
world's worst air quality levels in
seattle
san francisco los angeles and portland
spreading unhealthy air conditions from
canada to southern california i've lived
in pasadena for
almost 40 years now and this is the
worst that i've seen
in oregon more than a million acres have
burned in a week
killing at least 10 people including
peggy masso
and her 13-year-old grandson wyatt tofte
he was the
sweetest child wyatt's great aunt susan
vaslov
says the boy's father had left to get a
generator when the fire moved in
as he made a desperate attempt to return
he stumbled upon
a badly burned woman she can't talk
but somewhere along the line she either
scribbles it or she whispers it
i am your wife so he didn't even
recognize her
he left his wife who escaped on her own
with the paramedics and tried to find
his son but the blaze had exploded
two days later wyatt the couple's only
child
was found with his grandmother in the
family car
with his dog in his lap it just shows
how much heart he has
i think he's a hero trying to save him
and i think it does bring the family
some comfort
to know that he was really focused on
trying to save his grandmother
wyatt's mother remains in the hospital
we don't know her condition
and if she knows what happened to her
family scientists say there is no doubt
climate change
is fueling these mega blazes the
characteristic heat continues through
much of today here in the northern part
of the state
meanwhile the president expected to
visit to be briefed
on this disaster anthony just a
gut-wrenching and heartbreaking story
jonathan thank you